gaile good morning to you the NYPD says
employees at this deli right here behind
me did in fact call 911 also made
another arrest in this case but they are
asking for the public's help in
identifying more members of the
trinitarios gang as this community
continues to live and feed when I saw
those videos I was speechless I just
started crying
fifteen-year-old Brianna Gaskin was
friends with lisandro Guzman filiz his
murder has shaken her sense of security
here in the Bronx it's just scary it
really is scary to go outside and though
they turn our seats in your community
New York Mayor Bill DeBlasio was among
the crowds of mourners at a memorial
Tuesday evening outside the funeral home
handling services for Guzman Philly's
many in the community one officials to
take more action on gang violence have
grandchildren it's really sad that I had
to take a tragedy they'll bring a
community together
the NYPD is trying to calm those fears
this investigation is not over police
say eight suspected gang members have
been charged so far and more arrests are
expected the six men picked up in New
Jersey will be brought back to New York
later today after waiving extradition to
help locate other gang members who may
have been involved in Guzman felices
murder police posted new video showing a
14 year old boy being beaten and stabbed
by more than a dozen young men in the
middle of the Bronx Parkway and broad
daylight
many of the attackers are believed to be
the trinitarios police arrested one man
allegedly involved in this attack and
are hoping the community will help
identify more we will not tolerate thugs
on the streets of the Bronx
whether it's trinitarios or any other
gang involved in behavior this soon
the NYPD says the information that they
have received from tips online and also
phone calls actually helped them make a
number of arrests in this case they've
also said that there appears to be a
link in the Guzman Philly's case and the
teen who was attacked on the highway
John Marco Morgan with this
heartbreaking story thank you to Marco